Miriam has been in Tijuana with her
daughters for a couple of days the
journey from Honduras has been long and
difficult their goal is almost Within
Reach
the US border they don't want to stay in
Mexico for long the authorities here
have little to offer them they're making
no effort to provide food to be honest
the food they're giving us is awful look
here you would only give to pigs
but we have to eat it because otherwise
we'll die of hunger they'll sleep on the
floor again tonight in the city stadium
which the local authorities have
provided as a makeshift shelter they've
been overwhelmed by the migrants
becoming greater numbers than expected
Mario Asuna who manages the improvised
shelter says they're dependent on
government support
[Music]
particular mental wanna do is simply not
read with this we have no contingency
funds we rely on the federal government
for that in the field and provide a
system you see stellaris in los campos
but a has managed it for us to help the
people who are ready and will still
arrive esta
necesito que tenemos a keen seaman they
need as much as four million dollars
according to the spokesman for the state
Human Rights Commission he admits that
the city is currently unprepared for the
impending arrival of more migrants no
civilian this is the moment there's not
enough staff to receive all those who
say so inclusive and that is why we have
been putting pressure on the government
for about eighty million pesos was
submitted to the federal government
that's how much the local government
estimates will be needed for the
migrants some locals have been dreading
the arrival of the Central Americans
fearing chaos and costs in some
neighborhoods people have even organized
protests against them they have to
relieve themselves where they do it that
many people been was already going we've
given them a place to sleep drinks and
food but then in the news we see that
they are ungrateful
the truth is disappointing in the end I
was just starting my motorbike when a
boy insulted me we almost got into a
fight because he offended see a
synchronous airman a South Indian
increasing tensions have led local
authorities to impose tough security
rules it migrants are not allowed to
enter or leave the stadium after 10:00
at night